[Música]
o que faz as crianças a se perguntarem
tanto são tantos como tantos porque
dizem que elas são naturalmente
filósofos e cientistas porque trazem as
perguntas existenciais do conhecimento
são nascem com o impulso da busca
e é sobre esse impulso da busca que eu
gostaria de compartilhar com vocês
porque foi uma coisa que me acompanhou a
vida inteira e que me acompanha até hoje
e que não é fácil lidar com isso
por um momento de desespero de agonia e
de muitas felicidades de muitas
descobertas e eu não sabia porque até
que começando a refletir chegou essa
palavra de buscador e eu gostaria de
invocai vocês nesse momento nessa
presença nesse momento que reúne pessoas
tão bonitas porque ouvi lá fora
no intervalo jovens a idosos mas todos
com certeza trazem essa essência do
buscador no coração de vocês para
estarem aqui trazem a essência dessa
criança que quer brilhar no mundo quer
compreender a vida e encontrar o seu
lugar nesse espaço que ocupamos
quando eu lembro da criança que eu fui
lá atrás nas salas de aula é o
transporte
tanto pra agora certamente eu seria
classificado como sofredor do tt a que é
famosa déficit de atenção
um transtorno de atenção que inclusive
está sendo um fenômeno em muitas
crianças hoje em dia eu diria saudável
porque certamente se eu tivesse agora a
possibilidade de o estadual padre como
estão fazendo com as crianças nas
escolas primárias remédios tarja preta
sendo prescrito para esse tipo de estado
que pra mim foi o que me salvou de
muitas coisas eu ficava com o corpo
presente mas a minha mente ficava
viajando na tabela porque não aguentava
a superficialidade como raso era hippie
o que já está descrito no livro e fazem
isso hoje com as crianças na era da
internet naquela época não tinha a
viagem mas o que tava naquela reprodução
eu me sentia muito mal e não entendia
porque nessa busca eu terminei com ele
eo pior eu o esforço que tinha por que
eu não prestava atenção depois vai ter
que ter a nota é uma coisa horrorosa
porque tenho que passar e passava na
conta
acho que pela bondade dos professores
mas chegou o momento do vestibular e eu
descobrir que tava zero porque eu estava
tudo aprender no ano seguinte eu queria
saber era natural para mim isso é
necessário pra minha vida então foi um
ano de tortura para poder fazer um
vestibular que eu escolhi que era
eletrônica porque a palavra que parecia
que revelar os mistérios que eu busco no
mundo
era o que existia de mais quente talvez
hoje eu escolheria algo que funde se
física quântica com neurociência ser o
mais quente e conseguir pousar não sei
como
fiz um estágio na embraer é que era
coisa mais deslumbrante que poderia ter
meus colegas ficaram assim maravilha
tive a oportunidade de me transferir e
ficar trabalhando lá mas o ambiente
apesar de muitas pesquisas muitas
tecnologias do ambiente operário são
josé dos campos
eu sentia sem fôlego abafado e mais uma
vez essa criança buscadora apronta
comigo eu largo tudo e não quero mais
esse estágio e eu ficava nesse conflito
mas segui essa agonia essa dor e
sofrimento porque sabia que permanecer
no ambiente desse sofrimento seria maior
isso é uma certeza mas não sabia o que
eu queria te dei
a engenharia e vi que o ambiente
universitário seria o mais confortável
porque há um espaço acadêmico que
realmente senti que poderia respirar
melhor
foi agradável enquanto durou na
engenharia também sentiu os limites essa
essa pré são desse busca do que você
deve sentir e que muitos marcaram com
rivotril outras coisas o consumo do
álcool
essa pressão continuava e eu descobri a
possibilidade de fazer uma pós graduação
em engenharia biomédica achei
maravilhoso quanto estudar medicina
junto com a engenharia e os médicos
estão engenharia junto com medicina que
já tenho
fiquei maravilhado estudar o corpo
humano passei pelas disciplinas básicas
da medicina mas ao mesmo tempo emitem
uma frustração quando eu comecei a ouvir
as explicações do corpo humano como uma
máquina isso me revoltou profundamento
não aceitava me revelava contra os
professores
naquela época não tínhamos internet
artigos era via bbm um sacrifício para
conseguir descobrir alguns artigos
internacionais que falava de um senhor
diz que conseguiram modificar a
temperatura do corpo
voluntariamente e
desafiava todo modelo biológico que em
si nada até hoje
aqui existe um sistema nervoso autônomo
que nós somos passivos diante disso ou
seja nossos pensamentos nossas emoções é
outra coisa inclusive na ufpb quem
conhece a psicologia está numa ponta e à
medicina para a outra emblematicamente
demonstrando a desassociação que existe
do corpo e da mente nosso sistema é é de
medicina é terapêutico como um todo
não me conformava conseguir esses
artigos levei para o professor
ele está aí ó podemos interferir no
sistema nervoso autônomo elogiou o que
debochando edina mas essa coisa da índia
não sei como isso serviu pra mim eu vi
como o sistema estava morto
como aquela agonia de mim para a correta
como estava buscando conhecimento e uma
pessoa estava matando o conhecimento e
passando para os estudantes como se
fosse verdade última isso me criou uma
revolta na época
a revolta foi uma coisa que me
acompanhou muito me desgastou depois eu
compreender essa força que eu precisava
revolta foi um momento de conforto e bem
estar comigo mesmo que ainda luta para
conseguir mas quando ele pense isso é
coisa da índia desde então é pra lá que
eu vou
esse não é meu lugar não sabia como
nessa minha caminhada nem sim nem não
período surgiu a oportunidade de ir para
a espanha fazer um curso que me faria em
contato com essas culturas porque era um
tipo de antropologia southern concurso
maravilhoso três meses fui no meu
departamento de engenharia e disse eu
quero minha licença que eu tenho direito
para fazer um curso de antropologia
isotérmica o que valorizou técnica
daquele serviço mas minha essência
tentava você vai dar aula
mas eu quero minha linda e não ficou
aquela luta não deram aquela criança
teimosa buscador a mais uma vez vai e
larga tudo e fui para a espanha
quando voltei de uma viagem a viena e
agora o que vai acontecer quando você
chega no seu departamento
encontrei meu chefe com a cara fechada
você deixou um abacaxi pra mim e eu
dizer como é que você tem um cachorro e
ele riu e disse eu tive de dizer que
você enlouqueceu maravilha foi a única
solução para você manter cem tribos não
seria demitido por abandono de emprego
aí ele tem uma coisa agora você não pode
mais trabalhar nesse departamento não
tem espaço pra te eu sair num misto de
leveza e preocupação porque visitei as
outras saindo de uma coisa assim não
entenderia sentia essa busca e sentia já
uma sincronicidade porque quando estava
a ir para a espanha era barcelona e eu
ia e foi um otorrino pra limpar o ouvido
eu quero escutar bem o espanhol lá no
terreno de um diploma diplomado pela
universidade de taubaté x barcelona fica
na televisão barcelona me ligava isso
mas é incrível
sincronicidade que eu não vou pia que
existe na vida da gente maravilhosa
então nesse momento em que eu sentei no
campus da universidade andando ou o
andulo porque tava solto mas não tinha
onde pousar
cruzei com um colega que deixam a gente
está precisando de um professor
a filosofia da ciência no nosso patrono
sofia
fui pra filosofia apliquei para um
doutorado depois a fazer contas sem
contar as histórias que teve entre a ala
comunista ea área da teologia da
libertação que dominava lá e eu como
orienta livre era um corpo estranho
conseguir um e registrar para um
doutorado na índia com muitas caras
feias
fui e aquela criança disse tu não vai
voltar
o buscador ficou e passei 19 anos
aí fui 1990 a índia estava saindo do
período de gandhi e entrando no período
da globalização
conheci pessoas extraordinárias e sair
vendendo os jovens fazendo de tudo
inclusive ressaltando coisa que não
existia para poder consumir supermercado
porque na época que eu fui não tinha nem
coca cola a coca-cola estava em todo
lugar do mundo mas ainda que mantenha
uma economia fechada não permitiu a
coca-cola entrou
ele tinha os próprios refrigerante e tem
uma perspectiva mais socialista
digo vocês que lá foi onde eu pude ver o
potencial que existe dentro de nós e
como a mente interfere dentro disso eu
gostaria de fazer uma experiência com
todos nós aqui que é a seguinte é muito
simples vocês vão olhar e nos pulsos tem
uma linha abaixo da mão
vocês vão alinhar essas linhas aqui e
fechar as mãos
vamos juntar as linhas para garantir
como referência e vamos fechar as mãos
santo
aí vamos ver temos que os dedos são do
mesmo tamanho que são maiores as mãos
são um amor maior do que a outra
cada pessoa tem sua história ea relação
com as mãos
então veja que a mão que seja maior ou
se é igual vocês voltam os brasas solta
relaxa e escolhe um das mãos de
preferência maior você é igual tanto faz
imagina traz a criança
imagina essa criança desafiando a mão a
crescer a escorrer como se fosse um
racha a mão que você escolheu vai tocar
o chão
graça longa mão a longa outro permanece
da mesma maneira sinta isso sinta mais
do que pensa e traga de volta à mão faz
o alinhamento e compara e veja o que
aconteceu
uau para 90% pelo menos funciona ea
coroa e voltar com o corpo modificado
faz assim o show do grande e volta
normal esse é o mantra que eu aprendi na
gente
obrigado eu quero para finalizar dizer
que na minha experiência eu investi
muito no estudo do corpo humano e do
autoconhecimento e na volta pra cá
terapeuticamente eu pude comprovar
quantas doenças chamadas doenças
problemas têm o fundo é emocional por
isso hoje já sabe que existe a doença
chamada psicossomática mas ninguém pensa
na saúde psicossomática
ela está disponível pra nós do mesmo
jeito que a mente causa doença
nós podemos causar à saúde do mesmo
jeito que existe o efeito placebo
nós podemos usar a tecnologia do efeito
placebo de uma forma consciente
está tudo disponível dentro de nós essa
criança que me fazia buscar na verdade
está dentro de nós adoecemos quando
deixamos de alimentá lá ela traz muita
agonia mas quando você compreende você
relaxa mais não
fica aqui os desafios do mundo vão
desaparecer de forma alguma isso a nossa
condição humana mas a forma como vamos
lutando e vamos nos encontrando é que
modifica e eu espero que aqui vocês
sintam essa criança que tem dentro e não
abandonem por mais rebelde e desafiadora
que é nós precisamos desafio nós
precisamos de gente diferente
nós precisamos de rebeldia interior não
rebeldia e externa eu fui muito rebelde
internamente porque não compreenderá
espero que tenha a contribuído para
inspirar a vocês de alguma maneira
obrigado